what's going on reject nation we just
got back from watching a quiet place now
keep the horror thing go and we will be
doing a review for that but that takes a
lot longer to edit than anything else we
do but anyway we're gonna watch the
trailer for the first purge assuming
prequel let's get to it
[Music]
[Music]
for the better
[Music]
we came up with the participation human
nature does not obey the laws of
politics
oh damn they'd be forced to breathe whoa
they all ex-military funky going down
deep this is a conspiracy
[Music]
[Music]
live forth get ready to feel patriotic
independence man what do you think
Johnny or a purge fan these movies to me
are kind of like Freddy movies in the
sense that like there's always gonna be
a certain amount of crazy dream
sequences in a Freddy movie in a purge
movie there's always gonna be a certain
amount of just really spooky looking
people out and messed up masks and
stuffs like that aesthetic is always on
point this is a trailer overall though
like I like the look of all that crazy
stuff but I think kind of throwing out a
lot of the movie in this trailer yeah it
seemed like it went on for a while I
didn't really like the first one I liked
the second one and I did not see that
there this really doesn't look like it's
actually offering anything that
different I feel like that's what these
purge trailers tend to do they tend to
set it up like oh we're probably gonna
get some type of different exploration
or deeper understanding but it's just
gonna go down the same generic route
that I feel like they always tend to do
characters that are like cool I don't
really love them but they're cool what
do you know yeah I mean they always make
some kind of attempt to put a political
subtext forth and I just keep hoping
that one of these is going to like
really put that at the front the one
thing I would want these purge mobis to
do is kind of go into the more of it
like a memory so main character talking
about this is a psychological thing yet
I don't feel like this movies really
give us that sat there going that's a
cool idea this whole like psychological
experiment thing that's worth exploring
however most of what you're giving me is
just the action in the carnage yeah it's
like oh the same stuff I've seen from
the other purge movie yeah not to say
that they can't do it and you know James
demonaco seems like he wants to write
these with some kind of relevance but
that's just not what I'm getting from
this I feel like the movies always set
themselves up for that and then they
don't execute that in the last half
the movie and based on the way the plot
structure of what they're revealing in
the trailer I get the exact same feeling
it's gonna go down whatever the purge
formula is for their movies I was
intrigued by they launched the Persian
no one's really doing anything why
hasn't anything happening they need this
to work I want to see all of that as
much as I can be invested in the
character so we're on the streets who
want to be heroes and protect people on
the streets and whatnot well if you're
gonna do a prequel I wanted to stick
primarily to the government side I don't
think that's a bad way to go though if
you're really looking at the people who
are fighting against the PERT not just
trying to survive outside because we've
already now but if you're looking at the
people who are like no no no this is
wrong we shouldn't be doing this and
we're gonna go out there and do
something about it I think that's
another facet worth telling I just want
that to be richer than just oh they're
just gonna kill people in you know the
other the bad people yeah I mean to me
it's kind of just the frank grillo
different type of version of the Frank
Grillo storyline when he Frank Grillo
has a revenge mission but then he ends
up having to be a hero
well we already got to got that
storyline with anarchy from based off
the trailer for election year he's
buries another protector again and the
first purge too is about a father who's
protecting his family so there's always
the protection side I wanted to
primarily focus on why they want it to
work and what the point of it is
especially we're doing the first purge
let's really see what the necessity is
that behind the government every casting
Marisa Tomei I don't want her to be
wasted on this movie yeah for sure I
mean they they seem like they've
assembled a pretty neat cast I mean I
recognized at least that one guy from
insecure as well maybe another trailer
will like sell me on this because yeah
if it's the first purge I want to see
the discussion from all sides because
that's why yeah that's when the
discussion is the most potent cuz you
know you're a few years into the Persian
when you're like well you know the anti
discussion and the pro discussion are
already kind of been had so this is a
great opportunity to really dissect the
purge I just hope they do that and to
see like what the benefit is of it from
the first time it happened I want this
one to end in a way were it's like oh I
get why the government decided that this
should be something that we keep doing
by the time this movie ends on anything
about how this is affecting and bringing
out human nature makes a little bit of
twisted censors yeah yeah yeah yeah
alright guys well are you excited for
the
first purge and yeah okay you can
subscribe to the reject nation people
click that notification Bell again
notify when one of our vids is up and
you can check us out on patreon weekly
Q&A is full-length TV show reactions for
plenty of shows to do over there and a
bunch of other different kinds of posts
as well we'd love to have you become a
patron ejectives I